the real fight night Joe Biden mumbles
Bernie bumbles Warren fumbles in
everyone grumbles I'm Ben Shapiro this
is Ben Shapiro show now that's some
pretty outsized enthusiasm for what
ended up being a pretty soporific
debates hopper if ik in the dictionary
boring okay didn't put you to sleep
here's the thing there were some moments
there were some moments but how you
think that debate went last night for
the Democrats and it was the first real
debate cuz he got all 10 of the leading
candidates meaning three leading
candidates and a bunch of Lilliputians
you got all of them on one stage and it
was a brand moment oh it was going to
who's going to be the moment when we got
some clarity on the candidates yeah we
didn't instead what we ended up with it
was a bunch of people clubbing each
other with sticks and it wasn't really
particularly telling because how you
think the debate went last night depends
on what your expectations were going in
so if you thought that Joe Biden was
going to collapse and fall off the stage
you didn't quite do that and he sort of
stumbled around on stage knocked into
some furniture but he's still upright
right he's arrives if you thought that
Bernie Sanders was going to collapse
into pudding that didn't happen either
Bernie was just burning bernie is always
burning that guy's been burning since he
was 5 he's sort of like the high school
principal and back to the future that
guy was always bald Oh Bernie was always
burning and Bernie will remain Bernie
long after he's dead Bernie will be
stumbling around talking about making
the rich pay their fair share and if you
thought that Elizabeth Warren was gonna
have a breakout moment and and this is
where I think that the debate it didn't
change anything but it did change an
underlying assumption if you thought
that this was Elizabeth Warren's moments
of shyness she really didn't she really
didn't see what we have right now just
in terms of the dynamics of this
Democratic race is a three-way standoff
we have the very end of the good the bad
and the ugly we have three people and
they all have their guns pointed at each
other and it is utterly unclear who is
going to fire first and each person has
a sort of prisoner's dilemma with the
other members of the stage right the
worst possible option is for them to
open up their guns on the other members
of the stage but if nobody opens up
their guns then everything remains
exactly as it is with Biden eking out a
narrow victory over the combined voting
force of Sanders and Warren but for each
individual candidate they have no real
interest in starting a fire fight so
Biden did it a little bit with Warren
a little bit and Warren didn't really
hold up particularly well to it but the
fact is that each one of those
candidates sort of wants to avoid
conflicts with the other two so if
you're burning what you are hoping is
that Biden attacks Warren Warren attacks
Biden it they knock each other out like
a NASCAR crash and you just run on the
inside lane and win the nomination if
you're Biden you're hoping that
eventually Sanders and more entire of
being best friends and they go after
each other and you just sort of walk
through that metal lanes in the
nomination and if you're Warren you hope
that Bernie at a certain point gets
frustrated and takes out Biden for your
benefit but in doing so poisons the well
with all the Biden voters and all of
them end up with Elizabeth Warren so you
have all of these three candidates with
their guns pointed at each other but
none of them actually have an interest
in starting a fire fight so there's a
lot of talk before the debate yesterday
about maybe this was going to be the
moment when they opened up their guns on
one another but that's not happening
that's not happening and the person who
really in the end does need to break
away from the pact is Warren so if you
if your assumption if your baseline
assumption is that if Warren just keeps
doing what she's doing she wins the
nomination then she had a fine night
last night if your baseline assumption
is she does need to do something to
overcome Biden and that is my assumption
because the polling numbers at this
point as much as there's been talk about
her early polling numbers and her
gradual rise in all this she has no
support in the black community
Bernie support level remains absolutely
steady in Iowa right now Bernie and
Biden are running ahead of Elizabeth
Warren and in New Hampshire in several
of the polls Bernie is running ahead of
Elizabeth Warren if she loses Iowa and
New Hampshire she is toast right she has
to win at least one of those two races
which means I think she has to make a
move you add that to the fact that she
is obviously the smartest person on the
stage in terms of IQ and she taught at
Harvard Law School she has written some
pretty well cited articles on bankruptcy
and I've seen her teach classes right
and she is fully capable of engaging in
the Socratic method of engaging in
back-and-forth I really expected more
from her in the debate so my
expectations were disappointed you got
pretty much what you expected with all
the other candidates you got Biden who
was combative and old and half senile
but the truth is that that Biden is
actually pretty damaging in a general
election campaign why because all of his
foibles all the stuff that makes Biden a
bit of a weak primary candidate makes
him a dangerous general election
candidate including the fact that he's
old and kind of senile why because in a
general election that
fact is that if you are looking for
default candidate who doesn't scare you
Joe Biden looks a lot like that
candidate I mean the guy has to have
people choose mashed potatoes for him I
mean that's not scary right like there's
there's this clip going around last
night of David Muir asking Biden a
question and it's obvious that his
Polident came loose and those dentures
start shifting around his mouth and he's
trying to bite him back into his mouth
looking like Jim Carrey from the mask
and it's a real bad moment visually for
Biden and play a little bit of that if
you couldn't get it done after Sandy
Hook why should voters give you another
chance
because I god done before I'm the only
one up here ever beat the NRA only one
ever be thinner and he finally gets his
teeth back in his mouth there but it's
pretty obvious that his teeth are
slipping around
now everybody is saying well that means
he's too old in a general election if
the entire general election is premise
on here is an old man who doesn't
threaten you in any way that's not a
horrible pitch obviously because he's
running against Trump and Trump has high
toxicity levels so if you are trying to
run dead tree stump against Trump if
you're casting that in central casting
Joe Biden is that so even his gas in a
general election play okay so did was
anybody's impression of Joe Biden change
dramatically last night I don't think so
was anybody's impression of Bernie
Sanders changed last night of course not
because again Bernie Sanders is the most
consistent candidate in the field he was
is and always will be Bernie Sanders and
old red from the 1930s Elizabeth Warren
she didn't change perceptions but she
did lower sort of the estimation of her
skill level because she's supposed to be
the one with the plan right she's
supposed to be the one who is capable of
navigating the twists and turns of
turning people inside out she's gonna
prosecute the case against Trump cuz
she's so smart and she's so incisive and
she basically fumbled up there last
night I thought I thought she did not
have good answers to any of the
questions that were asked to her I
thought that she feels like someone who
is not comfortable with her own agenda
that's really what she feels like she
feels like somebody who feels like she
has to say all these things but doesn't
actually believe them Bernie is the true
believer Sanders is the new convert
who's sort of not into the whole
speaking in tongues thing right she
walks into the commie Church and she's
like well I get that I sort of have to
be a commie but at the same time I'm not
really a commie and so I'm really
uncomfortable with saying all of these
communists now
Bernie's out there going yes I'm gonna
raise our taxes yes I will spend all the
money yes I will bankrupt the country
sure like the hell dot and then you got
Elizabeth Warren she's like well well no
and people well you know your plans the
same as Bernie and Bernie's honest and
you're not right this is why a lot of
the Bernie bros look at Elizabeth Warren
and they're like she is a dishonest Paul
and that is correct she is a dishonest
bah okay so we will jump into the actual
content of the debate in just one second
don't worry that are gonna be debate
grades and we're gonna go through each
of the cans and it's suffice to say
Andrew yang is the only one who doesn't
receive the grade because Andrew Yang's
great is he andrew yang right he just is
Andrew yang there's no great he's not on
the chart but any everyone else gonna
give debate grades to have a lot coming
up first let's talk about how many cars
that are on the road so you're driving
around looking at all those cars and
maybe you think to yourself you know if
my car breaks down do they have these
specific car part that I actually need
you know over at the auto parts store
the answer probably not probably they
have some generic part in back that cost
too much money instead you should be
using the interwebs it's an amazing
place the interwebs you can be using
Rock Auto calm it's a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they've got everything
from engine control modules and brake
parts to tail lamps motor oil even new
carpet
whether it's your classic or daily
driver get everything you need in a few
easy clicks delivered directly to your
door
the rockauto.com catalog super easy to
navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brands specifications and
prices best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always reliably low and
the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers they've got terrific
selection reliably low prices all the
parts your car will ever need Rock auto
comm go check them out right now see all
the parts available for your car or
truck why get parts that aren't gonna
fit at the worst price instead get the
parts that are exactly right at the best
price right Shapiro's in there how did
you hear about us box and they know be
saying you go to Rock Auto calm right
now okay so we're gonna give grades in a
little while
suffice it to say this was basically a
giant holding pattern I don't think
you're gonna see the poles shift in any
direction one way or another I think the
media are gonna continue to try to
uphold Elizabeth Warren as the front
runner of the campaigns despite the fact
that in the Real Clear Politics poll
average she's dead even with Bernie
Sanders right now and both of them are
substantially behind Joe Biden with that
said I thought she under
last night I thought she had a real
opportunity to breakout and I think she
absolutely did not the big winner of the
debate as per our usual arrangement is
Donald Trump why because he had a bunch
of Democrats who were shouting at each
other about all the things they were
gonna take away from you your private
health insurance they're gonna take away
from your car they're gonna take away
from you your gun they're going to take
away from you your sense of the goodness
of the country they're going to release
criminals onto the streets they're gonna
take away from your border control and
didn't take all these things away from
you these Democrats and in return that
will give you enormous levels of
Taxation that was basically the policy
pitch last night now look the the
Democratic primary debates are about
winning a primary but there is something
that I think has shifted in American
politics since the Richard Nixon days so
the old Nostrum that Richard Nixon used
to throw out there about presidential
politics is that use a Republican you
run to the right and a primary into the
center in general and you've seen
everybody in politics abide by this
Nostrum that that on the if you're on
the left you run to the left in the
primary and you run to the center in the
general there's only one problem we now
have this thing called tape hay and
things that you say in the primaries
don't stay in the primaries the stuff
that you say in the primary debates ends
up resurfacing in the general election
and if that's the case good night for
Trump because the fact is that every
Democrat on stage basically pledged to
be incredibly radical except for Joe
Biden which is why I say the biggest
threat to Donald Trump in this election
is and remains Joe Biden why because
again he is unthreatening he's the
grandpa that you drop off at Denny's at
6 o'clock and pick him up at 6:30 you
bring him home you put him in PJs you
put him in bed he watches a couple
episodes of Matlock
that's not threatening it doesn't feel
like oh god he's gonna shift the country
out from underneath me and that's really
Biden's whole campaign is that he's
non-threatening and also that he loves
Barack Obama see that's the other
dividing line that none of the other
Democrats can get around
no one has stapled themselves to Obama's
pants leg with more staples than Joe
Biden I mean that dude took a staple gun
and just stapled himself directly to
Barack Obama's pant leg and last night
he made that obvious and he made that
clear and the other Democrats suddenly
realizing that wait a second Barack
Obama was pretty popular among Democrats
and particularly among black voters they
started to pay at least mild homage to
Barack Obama but the problem is they
can't draw contrast with Biden without
drawing contrast with Obama so again I
I don't think the Biden is out of this
race people are already counting Biden
out I think that he's a weak candidate I
think he's been receding but I do not
think that he is out and I was a little
bit encouraged by his performance if I'm
in his campaign and a little bit more
encouraged by Elizabeth Warren's
performance because she just did nothing
last night she was just a wet sack last
night I mean she just did not do
anything
okay so let's jump into how this debate
went from the very beginning so we begin
with the opening statements and there
the usual litany of complaints against
Trump Kamala Harris who has decided that
her entire campaign is going to be Trump
is horrible and mean and very very bad
so every answer she gave last night was
how mean and terrible and horribly bad
Donald Trump is she didn't give a single
reason anyone should vote for her
because there is no reason to vote for
camel-hair she's awful here as Kamala
Harris making her pitch Trump is a mean
mean man who's mean and doesn't mean
things the only reason you've not been
indicted is because there was a memo and
the Department of Justice that says the
sitting president cannot be charged with
a crime but here's what you don't get
what you don't get is that the American
people are so much better than this
there's nothing more stilted in American
politics than when a candidate says into
camera directly to your partner mr.
president I know you're listening to
this right now you're a mean bad man
look how brave I am for going right
Trump ain't watching that he was given a
rally in Baltimore where he was actually
pretty funny but this is common law
Harris's pitch is elect me because
Donald Trump is Minya good luck with
that
Bernie Sanders actually has a pitch hey
really like I think that people who are
who are treating Elizabeth Warren as
though she's a serious upgrade from
Sanders I don't think that's right I
don't think that's right Bernie is more
passionate Bernie is crazier
bernie is more consistent elizabeth
warren is occupying this weird middle
space between Bernie Sanders and Joe
Biden she wants to grab Sanders his
policy adherence while also appearing to
be somewhat more moderate like Biden
that's an uncomfortable place to be
she's sort of between a rock and a hard
place I don't think that the support
base for either one of those candidates
is in serious danger of a roading to the
point of disappearing here's Bernie
Sanders explaining in his typical
shouting at the sky Homer Simpson's
father fashion about how we need to stop
the oligarchy and by oligarchy I do not
mean people at the top of government who
want to steal all your money and
regulate your life I mean a bunch of
people who run
businesses we need to stop them because
they have provided me with these glasses
and all my clothing and the pudding I
still enjoy but they're bad we have got
to recognize that this country is moving
into an oligarchic form of society where
a handful of billionaires control
economic and political life of this
country
and as president I am prepared to take
them on Wow and he gave you the crazy
eyes he gave you the he swallowed an
entire shovel full of gravel before he
even started this impact he swallowed
fellow candidate Mike Gravel
right before this debate began that was
his pitch and then there was Warren's
pitch the Warrens pitches I'm so
brilliant I have a plan I have a plan
for everything yeah except that when you
were asked like simple basic questions
about your plan it didn't go great for
you here is Elizabeth Warren last night
the paths to America's middle class have
gotten a lot smaller and a lot narrower
today servicemembers are preyed upon by
predatory lenders students are crushed
by debt and families cannot afford child
care I know what's broken I know how to
fix it and I'm gonna lead the fight to
get it done
okay she is people keep saying she's
charismatic I see no evidence of
charisma right there I mean really like
we had prepared I'll tell you what we'd
prepared on the show we have prepared
for the possibility that Elizabeth
Warren would score some points against
somebody and then we're gonna play the
Jif of her dancing like a crazy person
in a rally and you know what it didn't
happen last night any of that so things
producers but we don't get to use any of
that sorry about that right we don't
even get to use this tape then we'll
just use it now because I mean why the
hell not I've Elizabeth Warren dancing
at a rally but that's not any excuse to
play this day basically I mean it does
not matter her dancing like Elaine in
Seinfeld or looking like Kermit the Frog
like that's yeah she is that's
electricity well she did not have the
electricity well NASA night joe biden's
case was basically I'm here I guess we
have to do this thing I mean you know
like we won't postpone it I'm gonna
quote JFK you can trust me because I'm
basically comatose go look this is the
you know
states of america there's never been a
single solitary time when we've set our
mind to something we were not able to do
it we're walking around their heads down
like woe is me we're the best-equipped
nation in the world to take this on it's
no longer time to postpone we should get
moving okay so it was no more postponed
but here's his real campaign postpone
everything hey let's not do this anymore
guys please please no more of this elect
the elect a man who has to be wheeled in
to to actually perform the office of the
presidency honestly the most honest
pitch last night as always the most
honest person on the stage my boy Andrew
yang Andrew yang the truth is the end
rehang likes business too much to be a
Democrat but at the same time he does
have the the most pure Democratic pitch
which is here's some money
so here's Andrew yang last night being
like you get some money and you get some
money and you get some money my boy
Andrew yang go for it
my campaign will now give a freedom
dividend of $1,000 a month for an entire
year to ten American families someone
watching this at home right now okay so
that's awesome okay I will just
acknowledge that that is P Buddha
jitters like that's a funny idea people
who judge was the worst okay people
booed a judge was awful last night like
really bad last night a lot of the
French candidates had their moment to
shine so Amy Klobuchar
did okay last night and and you saw a
couple of the other candidates do it
like Cory Booker had a couple of good
moments last night yang was yang Buddha
judge was terrible Buddha judge was
terrible Julian Castro was awful beta
O'Rourke is just the worst a beta
O'Rourke was so off the rails he thought
that he was driving drunk in court and
crossed a median line and Pino rock was
so bad okay we'll get to all of that
coming up in just one second first let's
say that you were watching that debate
last night and he wanted to die because
I mean why would you watch three hours
at that debate and want to live but you
haven't left anything to your family you
haven't actually made sure that you have
life insurance well this is national
life insurance Awareness Month you are
now aware you need a life insurance so
go be an adult make sure that you're
taking care of go to policy genius calm
right now getting life insurance doesn't
need to be difficult or expensive right
now prices are the lowest they have been
in 20 years policy genius has made it
easier than ever to get covered policy
genius is the easy way to shop for life
insurance online in just minutes
you can compare quotes from top insurers
to find your best price once you apply
the policy genius team will handle all
the paperwork and the red tape policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy they can also help you find the
right home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance their website is
extraordinarily easy to operate and get
this thing done really quickly I know
you're sitting there right now thinking
to yourself why in the world didn't I
just go get life insurance while I was
watching that horrible democratic debate
I mean I was sitting there for three
hours doing nothing and those are three
hours I'm never gonna get back you're
asking yourself the right question go
over to policy genius.com
right now and go check them out get
quotes apply in minutes you can do the
whole thing on your phone right this
instant
policy genius it's the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance be a
responsible adult do that for your
family policy genius calm okay so now we
get to the policy in the democratic
debate they have a big policy argument
it took up like the first 45 minutes of
this debate was health care so this is
always fun because basically I'm old
enough to remember when Barack Obama
claimed that Obama care was gonna cure
health care and that didn't happen and
now Democrats like you know would cure
health care if we tax the living bejesus
out of you and also get rid of your
private health care insurance and Joe
Biden is over there like guys guys yeah
well this is why Joe Biden continues to
be a fairly solid candidate in the
Democratic Party right now here's Joe
Biden really lashing out at Elizabeth
Warren this is the one moment where he
lashed out and Warren had no answer for
this here's here's Joe Biden explaining
your plan on health care really blows
it's really a terrible plan I think we
should have a debate on health care I
think I know that the senator says she's
for Bernie well I'm for Barack I think
the Obamacare worked my plan for health
care cost a lot of money it cost seven
hundred forty billion dollars it doesn't
cost $30 three point four trillion a
year turns out is twice what the entire
federal budget is that's before it
exists now without interest on the debt
how are we gonna pay for it I want to
hear tonight how that's happened so far
my distinguished friend the senator on
my left does not has not indicated how
she pays for it correct correct okay so
this is Joe Biden really he does get in
a solid shot here there's a solid body
shot against Elizabeth Warren and
Elizabeth Warren had no answer for it
and this is the problem for Elizabeth
Warren is Elizabeth Warren used to
be fully crazy Elizabeth Warren knows
better than the stuff that she is saying
right now and so she is uncomfortable
with it right Bernie Sanders is not
right if you directed that at Sanders
this is why he went after Warren because
he knows that Warren probably does not
believe a lot of the things she says
Bernie's a true believer you direct that
question at Bernie just goes we talk to
everybody
yes yep axes are gonna go up get over it
you go to Elizabeth Warren and Warren
tries to slip the punch by claiming the
taxes are not gonna go up that you're
actually gonna save money since your
employer is not gonna have to pay for
your health insurance anymore and then
there's a follow-up question to
Elizabeth Warren and she's asked okay so
do you really believe that employers are
then going to take the money that
they're not spending on health insurance
and they're going to hand it back to all
of the all of the employees like that's
that's not gonna be a thing here's the
Lizabeth weren't openly lying about
taxing the middle class
well middle class taxes go up will
private insurance be eliminated look
what families have to deal with is cost
total cost that's what they have to deal
with and understand families are paying
for their health care today families pay
every time an insurance company says
sorry you can't see that special in a
debate with Donald Trump that's not
gonna go well because she's gonna say
that in Trump's gonna say you still
haven't answered why you didn't pay for
it you still haven't answered right
aren't taxes gonna go up just a yes or
no
this is very simple our tax is going to
go up because everyone knows the answer
to this in fact this is why people like
Bernie because Bernie is at least Bernie
right here's Bernie going yep pretty
much tax is gonna go up deal with it
status quo over 10 years will be 50
trillion dollars every study done shows
that Medicare for all is the most cost
effective approach to providing health
care to every man woman and child in
this country I who wrote the damn bill
if I may say so
intend to eliminate all out-of-pocket
expenses Oh No birdies wrong about this
K when Bernie says that every study
shows Medicare for all will save money
absolute nonsense there's like one study
that says that all the others say it's
gonna cost an enormous enormous amount
money and Biden points that out he says
um guys you Bernie and you Elizabeth
you're just not telling the truth the
fact of the matter is we're in a
situation where if you notice you had to
answer the question this is about candor
honesty big ideas let's have a big idea
the the tax of two percent the Senators
talking about that raised about three
billion dollars guess what that leaves
you about twenty eight billion dollars
short the senator said before it's going
to cost you in your page there will be a
deductible in your paycheck you're going
to middle class person someone making
sixty grand with three kids they're
gonna end up paying five thousand
dollars more they're gonna end up paying
four percent more on their income tax
that's a reality that's not a bad idea
if you like it I don't like it okay so
that that is that is Biden saying the
exact correct thing okay and then you
get to it this is honestly I thought
that Biden for an old codger he didn't
do too badly last night here's Bernie
Sanders talking about health care and
Biden coming back with a line that
actually is not a terrible line let us
be clear Joe in the United States of
America we are spending twice as much
per capita on health care as the
Canadians or any other major country on
Earth this America
okay when he says this is America you
know not Canada he is correct now people
on the Left were laughing at him but the
fact is that when he says that he's not
wrong the fact is medical innovation
happens here you want a surgery are
gonna be able to get a surgery in the
United States of America
in fact his healthcare outcomes in the
United States are still pretty good when
you remove all of the con founding
factors in fact if you take away car
accident deaths and homicide and suicide
from the national statistics what you
end up with is the United States is one
of the top countries on earth in terms
of life expectancy so Joe Biden is not
wrong on any of this and again it was it
was a rough night for folks on the Left
who are gonna have to answer these
questions in a general election we'll
get to more of that in just one second
first
hye-rin can be a challenge as codable
cofounder Gretchen
nur discovered Gretchen needed to
hire a game artist for her education
tech company
she knew it wouldn't be easy to find
someone to grow with her team so she
went on over to zip recruiter zip
recruiter does not depends on candidates
finding you it finds them for you it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast Gretchen posted her job
on zip recruiter she said she was
impressed with how quickly she found
qualified applicants she also used zip
recruiter screening questions to filter
those candidates so she could focus on
the best ones that's how Gretchen found
a new game artist in less than two weeks
with results like that it's no wonder
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day like say here
at the Daily wire let's say that we had
a producer in his name was Robin let's
say that frequently there would be
injunctions to rob after the show to
make sure that something was cleaned up
in a piece of recording let's say that
didn't happen and so you sort of just
decided you know what
enough of this Rob and you decided
you're gonna go out and get another
qualified candidate through zip
recruiter you can make that happen
insanely quickly Rob that's something
that we could do really quickly through
zip recur comm CY zip recruit is
effective for businesses of all sizes
try zip recruiter for free at our web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that is zip recruiter comm slash
Dai ly WI re zip recruiter comm daily
wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire and also my
smartest way of threatening my employees
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire a
go check it out right now so as I say
the the leftists in the race the the
Bernie's I mean they're all left but
Bernie and Warren they Bernie at least
his honest Warren is not and that's why
all the people who are singing Warren's
praises after less I'm not seeing maybe
I may listen I could always be wrong I
can't engage the minds of Democratic
voters but if they think that she is a
formidable candidate based on that
performance last night I am not seeing
it now because she does not have great
answers for all of this stuff you know
Amy clobber chart o'clock at Bernie's
health care plan and she's exactly right
I mean I thought that kelabra chart
actually had a pretty good night last
night and here's the thing Elizabeth
Warren is standing there knowing that
what clappa chart is saying is correct
right Sanders doesn't have any clue that
what she's saying is correct because
Sanders still believes that Stalin was
great at his job but but but Elizabeth
Warren knows that and her discomfort
with her own policy positions was
evident throughout the debate now was it
a universally good night for Joe Biden
no it wasn't so who Leanne Castro who's
become the Kamikaze agent in this
particular race right I mean he's just
running into the middle of fields of
fire and trying to take out other
candidates in a desperate plea for
attention so who me and Castro he he
went after Joe Biden and he was actually
really dishonest about this so I'll play
the exchange and then I'll explain why
who Leon Castro is actually lying about
what Biden said he went in there with
one agenda with Joe Biden and that is
say Joe Biden is old try to say the Joe
Biden doesn't belong on the debate stage
because he's super old and homely and
Castro did that last night he's sort of
the chris Christie of the Democratic
Party here the difference between what I
support and what you support Vice
President Biden is that you require them
to opt-in and I would not require them
to opt-in they would automatically be
enrolled they wouldn't have to buy in
that's a big difference because Barack
Obama's vision was not to leave 10
million people uncovered he wanted every
single person in this country covered my
plan would do that your plan would you
do not have to buy in they do not have
to buy you just said that you just said
that two minutes ago you just said two
minutes ago that they would have to buy
you I'm fulfilling fulfilling the legacy
of Barack Obama and you're not I would
be surprised to him okay well again you
know Biden saying you know that he is
tied to Obama's leg is is correct so who
me and cast where there is obviously
attempting to you don't even remember
what you said two minutes ago it's not
true you go back and look at the
transcript Biden said that if you can't
afford insurance you'll be automatically
enrolled in Medicaid right that's what
he said but in any case that was the hit
on on Biden last night and it's still
the hit that Democrats think he's gonna
take him out is that he's real old now
again I thought hooli and Castro was
awful last night but you know III did
have a Godzilla let them fight moment
and that's when Julian Castro and P
Buddha judge went at each other two of
the more smarmy candidates on stage it
was pretty wonderful Buddha judge did
the why are we all fighting with each
other why can't we all be friends in
hooli and Castro was like because this
is a debate everybody of what they
cannot stand about Washington scoring
points against each other and poking at
each other and telling each other that
you're my plan your play look we all
know that's called
primary election points to Lillian
Castro it is so irritating when people
do this okay it's super irritating
you've seen it in Republican debates and
Democratic debates everybody's debating
it's called the debate and somebody's
like why can't we all be on the same
page Helene castor was like it's a
debate so I thought who lien Castro was
terrible last night but that was really
good that was really good and people who
judge deserves us cuz he is insufferable
he has become so insanely insufferable
and he really showed it last night
I do have to play you the the one other
relevant Andrew yang clip because any
time I have an excuse to play my boy
Andrew yang I'm going to so last night
he just decided randomly to announce he
knows a lot of doctors cuz he's Asian
which is weird and somewhat racially
discriminatory but sure go for it so I
know a lot of doctors and they tell me
that they spend a lot of time on
paperwork avoiding being sued and
navigating the insurance bureaucracy
yeah that's like me going up there and
being like I'm Jewish that means I know
a lot of accountants wait okay all right
oh yeah now here's the thing speaking of
the the rest of the Democratic Party the
truth is that the main candidates are
most Americans are sort of used to them
at this point right we're used to Bernie
we're used to Biden we're getting very
used to Elizabeth Warren but some of the
fringe candidates are helping shape how
people see the Democratic Party and
that's the stuff that's really good for
President Trump in a second we're gonna
get to the Democratic Party asked about
racism last night because this stuff is
really terrible for the Democrats and
every Democrat should be asked if they
agree with beta or works view on
American history that guy went from
being the supposed unifying moderate in
Texas to being a wild left Howard Zinn
spouting garbage machine and my goodness
you know just stayed up a little my bra
and I thought to myself how do I break
out from this pack of Democrats I mean
sure I skateboard and I do a lot of weed
but how do I really break I guess so I
guess I'll read some Howard Zinn and
just flips through like seven pages yes
you know what I never thought of this
before
America is racist brah we'll get to that
in just one second first great news
folks we are hiring at the Daily wire so
if you'd also like to be threatened with
unemployment in a zip recruiter ad you
can go over to our calm right now
thankfully our business is growing
rapidly
means we have more positions to fill how
we're gonna pay for all you people I
have no idea but go check it out right
now daily wired.com slash careers check
out all of the great job opportunities
if something looks right for you or
someone you know send us your
information ASAP again that is daily
wire comm slash careers come be part of
our amazing team and be abused by me on
a daily basis I mean just ask our
producers also and is that glorious time
of the week want to give a shout-out to
a daily wired subscribers so today this
honestly this is best shout out over its
Instagram or fighting and thriving who
clearly understands the rank strength
through adversities pretty amazing in
the picture she's holding her elite
beverage vessel in one hand with her
husband who's wearing a fantastic
Shapiro show shirt by her side holding
the other the caption reads getting
through third chemo treatment with the
help of my love and my new tumbler from
The Daily wire backstage live show
hashtag leftist ears tumblr hashtag t
NBC thrive our hashtag ben shapiro show
well god bless you and we are all
praying for you sound like an amazing
person and keep fighting because we're
all behind you really really cool thank
you for taking that picture thank you so
much for coming to the show and thanks
for posting that beautiful inspiring
picture and we are definitely praying
for you here at the ben shapiro show we
know you're in great hands at the Martin
O'Neill Cancer Center and we pray that
you keep fighting and thriving pretty
awesome stuff and congrats on being
featured on the Friday show also go
check out our Sunday special this
weekend so you should subscribe well I
should should you subscribe first of all
because we have to pay all our employees
right otherwise how are they gonna get
paid I mean they're basically
unemployable otherwise that's why you
should subscribe also to protect us
against idiots on the left one is he
platform us also cuz you get all sorts
of goodies right you get that beverage
vessel it's amazing the leftist here's
hot or cold tumblr also cuz you get our
Sunday special on Saturday so believe it
or not this Sunday I talk rap not
kidding there's a rapper named zoobi he
stopped by and we talked rap so for all
the people who were out there were like
oh sure P Rose erases because he doesn't
like rap I gave zubi a chance to make
his case to me about rap I still don't
like rap but at least I understand the
case a little bit better you should
check out the Sunday special it's a lot
of fun here's a little bit of a preview
I think one of the worst things you can
do especially to a young person is to
convince them that there's some kind of
victim and that the world is against
them and that they are oppressed
especially if that's not actually true
because I believe that whatever lens you
view the world through
is gonna be your reality it's a great
conversation also we talk about personal
fitness because zubi is ripped like a
maniac I mean this is a guy who yeah I
first got to know zu B's work when he
broke every British female weightlifting
record while identifying as a female for
like five minutes
anthem became a viral thing I helped
make it viral so zubi stop by it was
really great go check it out please
subscribe we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so we've gone through some of the
internal dynamics of the Democratic
Party race now it's time to talk about
what their agenda looks like to
outsiders so as I say if you had to sum
up the Democratic agenda we'll go topic
by topic in this particular debate on
health care it's we're gonna take away
your private insurance and raise middle
class taxes to do it so if that sounds
great I'll go for it America
alternatively we'll do it but we'll just
do it real slowly right that's sort of
Biden's plan okay then we get to racism
hey you ready for the so here's beta
O'Rourke after having read like seven
pages of Howard Zinn in a late-night
Doobie binge here is here's beta
O'Rourke desperately seeking attention
here's his take on America it's not
great racism in America is endemic it is
foundational we can mark the creation of
this country not at the 4th of July 1776
but August 20th 1619 when the first
kidnapped African was brought to this
country against his will and in bondage
and as a slave built the greatness and
the success and the wealth that neither
he nor his descendants would ever be
able to fully participate in and enjoy
I'm gonna follow Sheila Jackson leaves
lead and sign into law a reparations
bill that will allow us to address this
at its foundation
the fact that we have a white
supremacist in the White House and he
poses a mortal threat to people of color
all across this country he just called
Trump a racist murderer on the national
stage suggested that America's
foundation is slavery not that slavery
was a part of America's history and a
horrible part of America's history that
required the death of some 600,000
soldiers in a civil war and the bravery
of millions of African Americans and
allies in the in in the Reconstruction
era south in the Jim Crow era in the
Civil Rights Movement
he's not gonna talk about any of that
right America is just a dark horrible
place and Trump is a white supremacist
in the White House who poses a mortal
threat to people of color all across the
country which should come as a shock to
all the people of color all across the
country who have jobs now because the
economy is doing real well we have the
lowest black unemployment rate in
American history but apparently Trump
wants to kill all the black people
that's how he's lowering the
unemployment rate apparently he's going
around murdering all of the minorities
and then they're not on the unemployment
line so that's obviously what bata thing
I mean this is just insanity it's
insanity and if you think that Trump
ain't gonna use that sort of stuff in a
general election campaign the Democrats
cheering cheering as he says that
America was not founded on the 4th of
July but in slavery then we are
endemically racist and one of the things
that makes Beto's so repellent as a
candidate and and now as a human being
is that he is the he's the race
equivalent of the guy who declares
himself a male feminist
right the guy who says well you know
it's not just that I stand for female
rights I'm a male feminist I'm more woke
than the females are baito is more woke
he's more woke than anybody he's going
to acknowledge his white privilege he'll
elect him to president make that white
guy president so he can acknowledge his
white privilege from the White House
perfect pitch beta and then Cory Booker
comes out there he's like you know what
pea black people are in jail
disproportionately because of racism not
because people get arrested for crimes
and disproportionately those people
happen to be minority but just randomly
the police are just picking up black
folks and throw them in jail which would
be pretty wild if that were true but it
ain't so here's cory booker doing this
routine we have systemic racism that is
eroding our nation from healthcare to
the criminal justice system and it's
nice to go all the way back to slavery
but dear god we have a criminal justice
system that is so racially biased we
have more african-americans
under criminal supervision today than
all the slaves in 1850 okay there's a
difference the slaves in 1850 didn't
commit crimes if you're talking about
people who are in jail they committed
crimes that were convicted of crimes
slaves were innocent they were brought
here against their will and then forced
to work and give their labor to others
at the point of at the point of sword
effectively to compare people who are in
prison now two slaves brought over
against their will in many cases raped
separated from their families beaten I
mean it would come come now on I mean
this is this is insanity it's insanity
so you know this cut in Trump's favor
you bet it cuts in Trump's favor here's
Joe Biden watching his line and
suggesting that nobody should be in jail
for a non-violent crime nobody so I
guess Bernie Madoff about to get out of
jail that's exciting nobody should be in
jail for a non-violent crime as when we
were in the White House were released
36,000 people from the federal prison
system nobody should be in jail for
non-violent crime like no one how about
like drug dealing not drug using like
drug dealing that's a non-violent crime
let's say that you're dealing crack to
12 year old kids outside a playground
should you be in jail for that I feel
like sort of I feel like Ben yeah I feel
like that should probably be a jailable
offense let's say you commit
embezzlement that seems like something
you should go to jail for so later he
says well he meant nonviolent drug crime
again there are lots of drug dealers who
are in prison who are dealing drugs to
children should they be in prison yes
yes they should by the way the vast
majority people in print we've gone
through these stats before the vast
majority of people in prison on the
state and federal level are not there
for nonviolent drug possession offenses
and it's a minut percentage of both the
state and federal prison population but
we're gonna pretend this is all racism
and all the rest okay then the Democrats
get to gun control and this gets really
wild so baito
again just Leroy Jenkins sing the hell
out of this thing the Democrats are Cory
Booker literally came out this morning
and he was like you know Republicans
they keep after them a Republicans they
keep saying that that this is fear that
Democrats are gonna confiscate their
weapons that's fear-mongering as well
Cory Booker said and then we don't have
play Booker and then we have and then
bado is just like Leroy Jenkins Sears
Beto's saying I'm coming for your gun
yeah you and who else buddy hell yes
we're gonna take your ar-15 your ak-47
you know that we have this thing called
the Second Amendment in the United
States you are going to criminalize my
ownership of an ar-15 have I committed a
crime you're going to come to my house
with the police and you're going to
threaten to jail or shoot me if I don't
hand over my weapon that I own to
protect myself from criminals and from
tyranny
that's Beto's plan yeah good luck with
this in a general election cycle guys
again Joe Biden desperately trying to
cling on to moderation here I mean he's
like grabbing the hem of the Democratic
Party squirming cars guys don't do it oh
here's Joe Biden talking about how you
can't simply declare that you're going
to take everybody's guns we have this
thing called the Constitution and the
crowd cheering cheering Kamala Harris
saying we don't need a constitution
nobody's nobody cares about the
Constitution anymore old man listen to
this exchange it's astonishing you can't
do it by executive order any more than
Trump can do things when he says he can
do it by executive order does the
vice-president have a point there some
things you can many things you can't
let's let the senator answer oh I mean I
would just say hey Joe instead of saying
no we can't let's say yes we can she
breaks out that Joker laughs I mean that
is some creepy bleep hey Biden and at
the very end Biden gets laughed over he
says let's be constitutional we've got a
constitution and common law hairs like
all right all right Democratic Party
this is the route you want to go all
right and then Elizabeth Warren jumps in
and she's like you know what let's just
dump the filibuster right you know we
need to get rid of the filibuster okay
so I have this thing that I want to
remind Elizabeth Warren of you know he's
in charge of the Senate right now Mitch
McConnell you want to do this thing
I say Mitch McConnell should put up for
a vote dumping the filibuster today and
let's see how Elizabeth Warren votes on
it when it's Republicans in charge
here's Elizabeth Warren going yeah let's
just dump the filibuster and then we can
ram through gun control and confiscation
to the gun industry and unless we're
willing to address that head-on and roll
back the filibuster we're not going to
get anything done on guns I was in the
United States Senate when 54 senators
said let's do background checks let's
get rid of salt weapons and with 54
senators it failed
because of the filibuster okay also also
if it had not been filibustered if this
had happened under a Republican
president there's something called a
veto power so Trump would veto any a
bill of that sort but in any case and
when Elizabeth Moore if it was Obama
that was president then then the
filibuster was effective the filibuster
is there to provide yet another check
and balance against a bare majority
running roughshod over rights enshrined
in the Constitution in any case this is
radical stuff right the Democrats are
proving themselves to be radical
everyday and then people Buddha judge
jumps into the game on immigration he
just dumps out there's like yeah if you
support Trump you're a racist and by the
way you're going to hell didn't really
dump that last part that's been his
pitch his pitch has been as the holiest
man on this stage to support late term
abortion and be in the same sex marriage
as the most bible-believing person to
not believe certain sections of the
Bible let me explain to you my campaign
platform anyway here's Pete Buddha judge
saying that if you support from pure
racist so just to get that just to get
this straight according to bado America
is deeply and systemically racist
according to Cory Booker the only reason
black people are in jail
basically at all is because of criminal
justice racism and according to Pete
according to bado and the rest of the
Democratic Party Donald Trump is a white
supremacist racist murderer and
according to people to judge if you
support Trump's immigration platform you
are also a racist solid picture guys do
you think that people who support
president from and his immigration
policies are racist anyone who supports
this is supporting racism okay well yeah
go go go along with that so you support
border control your supporting racism
yeah now the best part of the Democratic
Party right now is that they also don't
have any solutions and and there are
places where they totally agree with
Trump but they just can't say so out
loud and so you end up with this bizarre
situation where their policies look a
lot like President Trump's policy but
they can't say it so on China there's
broad bipartisan agreement that China is
a national security threat to the United
States that they are stealing our
intellectual property that they are
pursuing
global ambition that they have built up
their regional power and that we have to
do something about it
every Democrat when asked about this
there they refused to just say yes I
agree with the president about China
here's what I would do differently
instead it turns into Trump's all wrong
about China all so I'm gonna do all the
exact same things that that China that
the trumps currently doing on trying
hears bootie judge trying to thread this
ridiculous needle I have a strategy that
would include the tariffs as leverage
but it's not about the tariffs look
what's going on right now is the
president who has reduced the entire
China challenge into a question of of
terrace when what we know is that the
tariffs are coming down on us more than
anybody else and there's a lack I mean
he's just speaking gobbledygook people
who to judge right there
so in other words Trump I would also use
tariffs just like Trump is using tariffs
but Trump is bad for using the tariffs
whereas I would be good for using the
tariffs solid-solid pitch and then you
get to Elizabeth Warren so here's here's
where Elizabeth Warren really is
passionate and just like Trump she does
not understand the basics of
international trade so she is I mean
much worse than Trump here is what she
says about negotiating trade agreements
but she's about to say is patently
insane patently insane she says that the
way that we should do trade policy in
the United States is we should have
American unions negotiate our trade
policy with China yeah that's gonna
happen we're gonna artificially you want
a trade war have our unions in the
environmentalists in the United States
dictate trade policy to countries with
whom we trade that is a great way of
never arriving at a trade agreement ever
for the rest of time because you know
who's not going to abide by our union
rules I have a feeling China or anyone
else you know he's not going to abide by
our environmental rules China or anyone
else like she's ripping on China about
his trade policies and then she's like
basically I would tariff everybody to
the to the moment it's insane we change
our trade policy in America is first the
procedures who sits at the table I want
him to go she a trade with unions at the
table I want to negotiate it with small
farmers at the table I want to negotiate
it with environmentalists at the table I
wanted to go she ate with human rights
activists at the table yeah I'm sure
that's gonna go great that's gonna go
fantastically well and then Kamala
Harris just sort of Leroy Jenkins is it
herself and she like seriously every
answer the Connell Harris gave last
night is I'm going to unconstitutionally
seized power and also I hate Trump so
she's talking about China and
just randomly calls Trump physically
small which is weird this Trump is
actually a fairly large room and being
here is Arras Kamala Harris doing this
routine and everybody cheering and
clapping Donald Trump in office on trade
policy you know he reminds me of that
that guy in The Wizard of Oz you know
when you pull back the curtain it's a
really small dude wow just wow that's
that's pretty spectacular hey also the
Democrats being radical on foreign
policy so on Afghanistan every single
Democrat said that they would completely
withdraw all troops from Afghanistan
they wouldn't even leave a trigger force
okay which is obviously against what Joe
Biden had to say Elizabeth Warren says
we should withdraw all the troops and
then we and then we will solve it with
with diplomacy which is always that my
favorite thing is when Democrats treat
diplomacy like it's a strategy diplomacy
is a tactic it is not a strategy a
strategy is where you come up with a
broad overarching plan for how you
achieve your goals maybe one of the
pieces of that plan is diplomacy like
Trump right now was trying to engage in
diplomacy with the Taliban but Democrats
seem to believe that if you just shout
diplomacy at things than they solve
themselves so Iran's a problem diplomacy
North Korea man they have nuclear weapon
diplomacy that's not a strategy
yeah idiots that's a tactic and if you
think diplomacy hasn't been attempted
with Afghanistan you aren't completely
foolish again Elizabeth Warren try Saab
the skater message Bernie Sanders just
dumps it right out there he's just like
I love the troops also we should fight
all of them and take away all the money
from the military Bernie Sanders man
owning it we cannot express our
gratitude to all of the men and women
who have put their lives on the line to
defend them defend us whoever responded
to the call of duty but I think also I
am the only person up here to have voted
against all three of trumps military
budgets well I don't know you can do
both of those things we're so grateful
for this for the soldiers also none of
them should have jobs also I'm not going
to fund anything they need salad salad
pitch okay so it goes like this right
climate change they declare that this is
the day after tomorrow that's what Amy
Klobuchar said and there was this
amusing point where Bernie Sanders
suggested that it's unfair to call
Venezuela socialist which is always fun
there was one more moment that is worthy
of note and that is again underscoring
the main complaint against Biden which
is that he's not with it so Biden was
pretty alive last night like for a man
who is not fully conscious he was fairly
alive last night and then there was this
one moment as the debate went on and it
moved into its seventh hour last night
Joe Biden started to lose some steam and
he was asked about education and he
ended up rambling about record players
which isn't a great look if you're
trying to rebut accusations that you're
too old and out of touch to be in the
race and you start rambling about a
technology that went out of style like
before I was born then that ain't great
here's Joe Biden rambling about record
players has an answer to education
social workers into homes and parents to
help them deal with how to raise their
children it's not that they don't want
to help they don't want they don't know
quite what to do play the radio make
sure the television the excuse me make
sure you have the record player on at
night the phone make sure the kids hear
words a kid coming from a very poor
school or a very poor background will
hear four million words fewer spoken by
the time they get there okay so what
he's going for here is there are these
studies that show that impoverished that
particularly parents are single kids and
you know single single parents of
children that they speak fewer words
their children and children develop
differently based on that that language
deficiency that's what he's going for
there instead he's like turn on the tip
well I can't say turn on the television
set actually it's not good for kids put
on the record player record players have
not been relevant since approximate I
mean like put on the phonograph put on
the phonograph we need the phonograph
put on some Benny Goodman all right Joe
so okay time for some very quick grades
and then we'll get to a quick thing I
like an a quick thing that you know we
won't even do things I like her things I
hate her the quick raids last night's
debate grades Biden b-minus
because He fulfilled expectations but he
had a couple of gaps Bernie was a
because Bernie is always a B Warren was
a C because I thought that she didn't
fulfill expectations Buddha judge was a
D because he's just terrible clobber
char I thought was a b-plus but nobody
cares because she's irrelevant Castro
was an F because he's deeply annoying
and horrible Cory Booker was a B we
didn't play any Cory Booker because he's
not super relevant but I thought that he
performed okay
beta was an F because he's awful Kamala
Harris was a D but shading into an F cuz
she was awful - and Andrew yang was he
hang back those are the grades
those are your debate great alrighty
well
you know what we're not even adieu
things I like in things I hate because I
had to expend too much energy putting
together today's show but if you want
more analysis of the debate if you want
to hear about President Trump's
appearance last night in which he called
himself orange which is a thing that
happened and was kind of hilarious you
can tune in a little bit later today we
have two additional hours it's one of
the reasons you should subscribe over at
daily wire.com they also will be doing
mailbag and questions and all sorts of
fun things you should go subscribe
otherwise it's a Friday have a great
weekend i'm ben shapiro you're listening
to the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jessica alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you